i said that my life shifted in like
three cataclysmic moments first one was
that day because as we're about to our
name be called my mother gets called and
she finds out that i never let her leave
and they said they made a mistake but
her father was a very very big figure in
cuba years back and she was very vocal
about you know her anti-communism stand
so she was or he he was no she was she
was also vocal when you say vocal what
does that mean in another sense that for
example one of the things that fidel did
is let's say your son all of a sudden
when he gets to be 12 and you're living
him in boca raton he's going to take
your kids from your house and he's you
can send them to california
and you're going to send some kids from
texas to your house why
because as we're going to school
they have what they call the pioneers
and the pioneers like the boy scouts but
it was their way of indoctrinating the
youth right into the communist ideal
so if i go home
and i tell my mom like i would what i
learned in school right there's no god
that's just uh poor excuse for the poor
and my mother gives me hell well it
stays there but if i come home and i'm
living at your house and your wife tells
me that oh that's a bunch of bs and i go
back to school and tell the teacher
your wife will go to jail got it what a
way so he was a family so he was
breeding snitches and how to break up
families oh
i mean the first thing he did as far as
niches was every block had a snitch
every block had what they called a
committee the committee they reported
everything that went on just somebody
sat on her chair and rocked and took
notes of cars coming in whatever was
going on
so that's what he did and my mother said
well before my children turn 12 i'm
taking him out of here
and you know my mom was born with a
silver spoon in her mouth her dad was
you know her dad at the age of 16 went
to the independence to fight with marcel
against spain and came back a general
and highly decorated until this point
the military base where he's from fidel
castro still named it after him that's
how much of a big figure he was like one
of our founding fathers here so
uh my mother of course she would curse
out the committee she didn't give a damn
about anyone she was i said my mother
was five foot man she had been five 5'4
she'd be a terrorist
but strong personality yeah uh
unbelievable and uh so she's like
leaving well
she doesn't get to go and my father said
well if you're not leaving i'm not going
to leave
so my father comes to me i'm ten my
brother's nine my sister's five my
mother comes and grabs my hand and says
george you take your brother's sister to
miami i'll see you one day
and that to me
like my whole world rocked because my
father like i'm not coming he eventually
he did get on the airplanes we were
boarding
and uh so we went from living a house
that was one square block
each kid had a car you know very well to
do to 11 of us living in a one bedroom
apartment in miami where we had to write
down what time we're going to piss
because everyone had to go to school
work
so all of a sudden when i got to miami
it was my first cataclysmic moment all
this stuff about god that my mother's
been telling me
mom you know what what they were
teaching me school was right
there ain't no god this is obs if we're
coming from cuba to be with god and this
is god's joke you know and uh
so i grew up till many years later a
die-hard atheist and uh and then the
next day was
when this drive in me
awoke i i encountered my american dream
what was that
my cousin who had been there about a
year year and a half earlier comes to
visit us
and he has
a candy apple red
white interior
gto
man patrick was like
this is it the day i get that i'm going
to be somebody in america yeah
but you know my father was a man of
unbelievable principles you know my
father uh we had no food to eat
you know we we'd get two raw eggs and
the spotted milk that they gave us that
till today i take milk and i want to
vomit
and uh
and that's all we would have to
dinnertime and dinnertime with rice and
beans he's making 85 cents an hour
minimum wage doesn't speak english 40
years old three little kids
rent eighty dollars
i mean we're literally going through
hell well i find out that my friend has
lunch at school
and man i to me was a big discovery i
couldn't wait to get home and say hey
dad dad i found out my buddy
he has lunch he has a sandwich
to me a sandwich is like now having a
three pound lobster and he's like you
know you know the old uh generation
didn't speak much you know kids were
meant to be seen not to be heard
so
he just nuts his head
and he's like uh i said he tells me he
gets footsteps
i said dad do you know about footsteps
and he's like
lost his head i said well why don't we
get food stamps that
he's like some because that's for poor
people
and i looked at him patrick and he was
like holy crap
we're not even poor yet you mean we
still gotta climb our way out of
wherever that's called to get to poverty
i said dad
we're not poor
he pointed a finger in my chest and said
no son we don't have any money
people that take money from the
government are poor gonna stay poor you
figure out how to get up early and help
feed your family i was 10 years old i
weighed probably 90 pounds unbelievable
and at 5 30 in the morning i've been
getting up ever since that day and i'm
65 today
so if you like this sort of short clip
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire interview and
please don't forget to subscribe to the
channel take care everybody bye
[Music]